there was a moment on Sunday or Josh and
I looked at each other and we only heard
something it was a red alert it was a
moment that we knew was coming for a
very long time I didn't know where you
were going we batten down the hatches
right we called for backup right and we
said oh my god it's happened Blake
bortles was benched and the only thing
that I wondered in my little pea-brain
little pea-brain was his sims at home
right now feeling happy feeling sad or
is he standing up on his couch and going
I told you so give me all your truths
what what were you doing I can't say I
was shocked but not shocked after he
fumbled the second time and I was
keeping my eye on that game of course
cuz it was one of my favorite games of
the day really to watch and as I was
watching that you know my thoughts about
him already I can always tell when he's
not sure where the ball is gonna go on a
given day from the beginning of the
being of the game his first throw of the
game the ball comes out of it and he
anybody that's out there watch on TV or
watch on film whatever he hops around
I'll throw the ball and a hop like oh
gosh I hope it gets there oh I hope it's
good like when you bowl and you're
wanting it to curve you're like is that
kind of stuff exactly right where he
hopped so that's to me when I when I
start to see that Blake bortles I got oh
he has no idea where the balls going
today he's just hoping it goes where he
wants it to go and that's really been
the theme for the last three weeks is
that type of play so it started out like
that you know their offense was stagnant
then of course his turn to turnovers led
to ten points yes deep in his own zone
right and I thought man after he fell in
the second time I said man they are they
don't they won't pull him out they'll
probably let him go at least another
series or two and I looked up and I was
like oh my gosh number six is in the
game and there you had it Cody Cody
Kessler so so where do you want to start
I don't miss Ben your ship well I mean
it's my ship first of all I mean if I'm
gonna just
cheap shots that everybody I wanna go
where are you people where is everybody
that wanted to tell me a black Blake
bortles winning the AFC divisional game
in Pittsburgh and playing great in New
England and playing great in week two of
New England this year and I just it's
been four weeks in a row of horrible
plan I don't hear anybody ever come to
me and go all the haters of the
Twitterverse and Instagram I'll hear
anybody go damn Chris you know what
we're wrong we were wrong you were right
sorry man because I know I do that all
the time when I'm wrong I say I self
scout myself I get out there I just want
some of the apologies that's what I want
and then my other thing went to anger
you know I went to anger because I went
to anger because I wanted to be like
[ __ ] Jacksonville what were you
thinking with this what did you think
was going to happen you did this yeah
you did this this is your fault
you made this bed deal with it you said
to us in the off season he's five he's a
good personality everyone out there is
hating on him right this is all over the
top we trusted he's a great leader right
I mean they never talked about his play
that's the thing that you just have to
read between the tea leaves to go and go
well the team doesn't really think he's
good they say everything they avoid all
conversation about his play on the field
it's always something else I he take a
hit for him he's great in the locker
room I like when he runs into people
remember there was a whole article about
him running people over yes so you would
like an apology you're you are upset at
Jacksonville I am a set of judge because
their window is a closing right we're
seeing it on the defensive side of the
ball because it's funny when you look it
up and you go they did allow 20 points
okay Houston scored a field goal because
they got the ball in Jacksonville 36 off
the board exactly right and then as you
said they got the ball Jacksonville's 12
which led to a touchdown yes their only
other touchdown they started at the 40
which I can pretty much guarantee you
Jacksonville did nothing on offense
before that drive and then punted it to
the 40 exactly right that was that was
the game and Jacksonville's defense was
phenomenal in the football game I don't
know what other way to say it but when
you got to play beyond the field all
game long and the pressures on you every
week to win the football game and I know
they haven't been at their best the last
few weeks but last week they hung in
there
Dallas for a long time you know there's
just when the offense is constantly
going three and out six and out three
and out yeah I don't care who you are
the 85 Bears would have had a hard time
being the 85 Bears if that was the case
you know it's just too tough and it's
unfortunate because like we've said this
is one of the best teams in football and
fournette getting hurt for not getting
hurt and then losing cam Robinson on the
left tackle at Sims the Jaguars were
undefeated when fournette didn't play
last year oh I know that's like mortals
was a better quarterback when fournette
didn't play I thought they were better
without fournette yeah they're not
because fournette is a sledgehammer and
it's a there's no value you could put on
a guy again where it's first and ten and
there's nothing nowhere to go
or nothing to do and he could still run
for three and four yards and keep you in
second and six and then Blake bortles
can throw is running back screen or a
shallow cross or throw the guy in the
flat off the bootleg and those are the
things that aren't there now because
there's no run game